speaking of dad bods uh leo
i i believe he's the guy who made dad
bods famous so this was the the
the picture that at least i remember
that made dad bods famous this was
leonardo dicaprio on drugs rolling
around and i believe this is central
park
in new york city with a nerf gun
uh water gun just having the time of his
life okay and so i mean when did you
start hearing about the term dad bod
maybe five ten years ago as dad bods
became a thing right
and let's pull up some pictures of other
famous dad buds because i want to get
your guys opinions on this so
there there was a study adam sandler i
love adam okay so
adam sandler click on that there was a
study done to pull up some pictures of
sir famous look at will smith there was
a study done
um
this past year
that said 75
of single women
dad bods
over ripped guys with abs six packs and
all that so basically beer belly looking
dudes
over
guys with six packs so
we're looking at these pictures we're
talking about leo he made this famous
there's seth rogen there's a dad bottom
i've ever freaking seen one right there
um
robin thicke looking a little thick with
a couple c's right there who else you
got here there's jack black boom hit on
that is more than a dad but that is a
keg that is and then pull up this
picture over here of um not david
beckham right above him
you got um what's homie's name right
here
total start of a kid above right right
there what's his name again
zac efron ripped diesel
so ladies
dad bods
or abs bods do you have a strong opinion
on this oh yeah you do yes go ahead
amber men you have the best marketing of
all time leave it to men to brand
a dad bod as sexy while we're here
[ __ ] doing bbls and
every woman is investing in completely
reinventing her body and dad bods become
hot oh yeah man let yourself go it's
fine it's sexy good for you [ __ ] that
so you're not you think it's just a
marketing it's a pr spin yeah i think
that there may be some psychological
aspects to it that dating a guy with a
dad bod may be as a woman you feel a
little bit more comfortable just like
being your natural self and not like in
the gym fighting to to to make it to the
female standard of beauty
maybe that's why they like it it's like
comfier it's more approachable
in a relationship sure but no i'm
attracted to the muscles so you're more
into the abs again it's so the people
who come with the abs yeah tend to not
be
highly emotionally intelligent okay so
you're saying that you're saying their
bodies you're saying that the the the
hotter the more ripped you are the less
emotionally available it's a very big
general generalization but i would say i
tend to tend to think the same with
women too so if you had a
leonardo dicaprio dad bob looking dude
or zac efron ripped chisel dude you're
saying you prefer the zac efron type my
eyes go there first okay
how about you jenny my truck record
shows abs
so what you date athletes
ripped guys just like i mean i don't
like them rips like i don't like guys
like guys they're in the gym and they're
like
and they're making all these noises
i have a theory about that i have a
theory about that but i'll save it for
i'll save it for an x-ray don't save it
um
yeah i like them i like them lean lean
cut
muscular
cut like you don't have to be no you
don't have to be super shredded but i
like you like lean and like
so but same okay
but when like once we're together we
have kids and you if you get a dad like
a dad like i'm cool with it like you
don't have to be like you know what i
mean i'm not saying guys
while you're single no kids you want the
the ripped guy but when they start to
have kids if we have kids and that
happens
yeah and my body changes too except me
for two honey like we both accept each
other
do you want to be the hot one in the
relationship like meaning
if you get let yourself go a little bit
and your dude was ripped would you feel
self-conscious versus you you girls are
obviously in shape your dances you're
hot and you're your man isn't as
hot as you where's that you always tend
to see a hotter woman with a less
attractive man yeah that is always
of course because men are more visual
and women are more looking for other
things you know
so you're asking if it's more
comfortable you feel more secure being a
hot dog in the relationship i like being
hot with my men
yeah it's nice when you have somebody
who like we're both
you want to be proud of your person okay
but you don't like you don't have to be
the most beautiful thing in the world
you know what i mean
like are you talking about man or
yourself i know a man
even ourselves like there's always going
to be somebody pretty you're always
going to be somebody better but listen
amber yeah you you you said that that
it's a marketing ploy which is amazing i
kind of think it is
but
women said 75 of them preferred the dad
buds they could have said they want the
ripped guys like you guys just said so
walk me through the process
women who have bodies that are letting
themselves go in the same range of
characters if you had jen aniston and
courtney cox and whatever nicole kidman
nobody would be like oh it's so sexy
they're they're mom bods
no well that what's funny is i don't
know if you want to pull up this article
if you have the link the whole article
was dad bods are are now famous
but are mom bods dad bots are hot on
celebrities exactly where's the poll of
women saying dad bods are hot just
normal men those celebrities of course
leo dicaprio and all the a lot of those
men are hot in our minds and seeing them
as like real men and it's what women
associate dad bods comes with yeah it
demands that they're dads they're like
we're we're thinking of them as father
figures that's sexually exactly like
theirs
what comes with the body exactly he's a
dad he's just a stroller he's like he'd
rather fold laundry he's taking care of
the dishes
he's paying the bills he's bringing he's
bringing home the bacon
nintendo that's okay so we are missing a
key ingredient here
a key ingredient in the dad bod is the
fact that you are a dad okay exactly
you're not that happy you're not you're
not you're a fan you can't have a dad
without being a dad you're well you know
some of us out there yeah
so so that's a key ingredient is that
it's the connotation of what comes with
the dad bod is that your dad you're
taking care of the kids you're you're
paying the bills you're you know you're
making bring it home to bacon you're
taking care of the family you're a
family man yes and that is attractive to
women not like beer gut all right
everything we just talked about we've
gone off on tangents but this is dating
101 yeah go ahead all right
she sat up a woman yes because i'ma
break it down real quick and real fast
let's hear it
a woman
you ask her how her relationship is with
her father that will tell you so many
things you need to know about the
relationship all right women what they
seek a lot of women what they seek in
men is what they wish they seeked in
their father all right so if they know
you're a good father and you're present
and you're not so selfish or
self-centered that already warms their
heart because that's what they want to
attract that's what they want as a
spouse that's what they want as a father
of their own children
so it comes with a sense of like oh he's
mature he gets life oh he gets this he's
not just in the gym every day working
out and an airhead and doesn't
understand everything this is speaking
generally i'm not speaking specifically
that's not the case
you know what i mean so what when it
comes to stuff like that when women see
dad bods that's what they associate with
like oh like that nurture that this that
that so it's not about the dad body it's
about the what's inside of that dead
body and what comes with being that
jenny [ __ ] about that lady now you
know now you know dad bods 101 i mean
you want to clap back on her do you want
what do you want to do here
uh clap no clap clap four no
ladies supporting ladies right there
you